[Music]
oMG of course it's a yes I really am
blown away here oh yes a million times
grab your tissues America's Got Talent
delivered some seriously epic
performances during Tuesday's round of
auditions I'm Angelica Hale and 9 years
old and I'm in fourth grade I love to
sing Angelica who nearly died before
receiving a kidney transplant from her
mom when she was four completely stunned
the judges and made it through to the
next round
[Music]
then there's 29 year-old Mandy Harvey a
longtime musician who lost her hearing
at 18 everything that I had ever wanted
was just going away and I couldn't stop
it Mandira learned how to sing and
clearly all that hard work paid off
[Music]
I don't think you're gonna need a
translator for this
[Music]
and get this there's actually a dog that
knows how to do math meet Mia the canine
Einstein who can count up to 50 and read
flashcards if you like to choose a
number that you would like for her to
count to I'll tell her to count it for
you for Mia count to four
[Music]